[Musique]
une séquence de la campagne officielle
de 74 celle où vous militiez pour chaban
avec un agronome en pull-over rouge qui
tentait nous alerter
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes animaux
rené dumont le premier candidat écolo il
avait raison il avait raison et pas
raison à la fois mais il avait raison et
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour les gens
de conviction
lui aussi on aurait pu dire qu'il était
don quichotte mais on s'aime toujours
des petites graines qui évolue la preuve
et il a raison c'est un d un des défis
majeurs
simplement on le prend par le mauvais
sens à mon avis voilà c'est à dire que
on se donne bonne conscience alors que
là le seul moyen est ce ce que je
propose de d'éviter l'explorer chauffe
mans climatique et le désert des océans
j'ai fait un rapport là dessus c'est de
mettre fin à la mondialisation inhumaine
c'est à dire de mettre des barrières
douanières de couper avec la chine qui
est en train de de faire exploser la
planète à chaque fois qu'on consomme
allemand ou chinois
on participe du gaz à effet de serre
c'est que n'ont pas compris nos écolos
[Musique]